to have a me good morning oh yeah good
afternoon good morning
so look Ryan been looking forward to
this I think I think it's safe to say
there be a lot of people keen to know
the Ryan Adams story mate we see all
over the LinkedIn and we see you online
so I'm excited to talk about the
realities and what's going on right so
and where I always like to start this
podcast mate is how did Ryan Adams enter
the world of recruitment let's start
there okay so many moons ago now
probably show my age look how long you
been in the industry for I think well
over thirteen years let's go 12 to our
okay at 2007 I think off the top of my
head okay and early 20s as most people
do yeah a really long story short the
way that I got into recruitment was I
used to play semi-professional football
words I think a lot of recruiters did
and I've done pretty well of my football
career okay I'm in the heyday and I
played for a team called Tooting in
Mitchell who were in rhyme and Lee yeah
and you know used to get on a bus get on
a train tram taxis well over the place
just to play football alongside being a
personal banker at the time at Barclays
Bank yeah and there was this guy that
played for my team mix race guy always
in like tailored suits haha off shoes
had a Rolex that's the fresh haircut
just looked just look the part basically
wanted to be like him
just for reference is a guy called Paul
Bogle I'm sure a lot of your audience
would probably know okay and he worked
for a company called s3 and as my career
and working in the brand computer
futures yes he sold you the dream he saw
me the dream yeah okay now if you if you
want to be like me when you come and
meet my company in London we do
recruitment had no idea what recruitment
even was back then but yeah hey I mean
if I can get a Rolex in a nice suit like
this
Happy Days just to just to frame it up
then so entered the world of equipment
and so how long did you work at s3 for I
went to s3 for maybe about a year and a
half so okay so eighteen months and then
is that when you join console yeah so
actually no sorry that's all I have to
go back away so yeah I had a about a
year and a half spree and it was amazing
like really really enjoyed it learnt
recruitment the hard way yeah with some
amazing amazing recruiters so Dave and
Ashley who own trust and so dar yeah so
that's where I get very good people yeah
did some amazing amazing people and I
had an amazing time there I was a
contract biller Rookie of the Year when
he has hit lunch clubs you know I got my
run rate up to about 40k per month and
was doing really well and I decided that
I wanted to go and work for a smaller
company and be a big fish in a small
pond and I made the bread management
even I joined a company called
Devonshire who yeah may-maybe not as
well known as some of the other
companies that I've worked for but we're
there for about a year and a half as
well okay so whatever year and a half so
yeah so free is between those two
companies enjoy consul partners where
you had a real solid spin like six and a
bit years young nats and then after that
he then or she decided to start your own
recruitment business yeah yeah exactly
no console was probably one of the
biggest defining moments of my career
because I spent seven nearly seven years
there and most of my twenties and I
learned I learned a hell of a lot there
right I joined them as a senior
recruiter and left as a shareholder in
the director so a lot of the stuff that
I have taken with me into my new
business I probably learn at console
yeah I think that's that's very that's
gonna be quite typical con that a lot of
people so as I said made before we
started this we're definitely focus on
the signified journey but I guess with
you just sharing that that it was a
pivotal moment to you
pivotal part of your career I guess what
was just coming out that when you
sharing now which I think me very
interesting there'll be a lot of people
listen that are probably aspiring to own
part of the biz
that they work in as an employee so I
guess in hindsight what what do you
think of some of the contributing
factors to you get into that points I
think a lot of people be working to that
so looking back how do you think that
you got to that point alone and part of
that business yeah it's a good question
so I joined them when they were only
probably about two years old okay like
some ten people so it helps firstly
doesn't that when you're an early early
part of the generally so I think taking
the taking the risk on kind of a startup
I guess that weren't really well known
in the market definitely buying into the
leaders yeah what Malcolm Graham was was
really really cool and they're both like
super inspirational motivational and
just like real real hard workers and
they showing a lot of stuff that I do in
my daily life right now okay only 20 so
yeah just just choosing a business going
somewhere right and super ambitious big
growth plans and they didn't actually do
contract recruitment before I started
there so me and another guy were tasked
with building their contract division
from okay and they were say gonna do my
market ivar so it was a big risk but
definitely paid off and I learned a lot
there I learned a hell of a lot I was
one of their biggest bidders a group
team from scratch and it was really fun
we went from 10 people to a hundred of
people mm-hmm
grew our headcount grew the NFI opened
offices in LA and they surprised places
in the US oh okay
I guess yeah there's choosing a company
you you've really believes gonna go
somewhere and once they grow they give
you the opportunity to grow as well and
I went from a senior to a team leader to
a manager to a director so it's a really
fun job
so I guess what did you take that
because what it seems like then from you
sharing that is I think it's fair to say
that you delivered a lot of value right
so you started something that they
didn't have and etc so but did you did
you proactively and constantly have
those conversations of look guys really
buy into you and really see the
opportunity here but just so you know
this is one gun in for like I do want to
impart this company I do want to add
tremendous value so because I think that
that's the thing where when you are in a
smaller business you've got you've got
show that you want it and said that this
is where I want to be guys I wanna take
us deep reversal with that yeah
definitely a really reactive I think
that was part of my I be honest with you
my early career
like most recruiters I didn't really
know what I wanted I just I just fell
into the job yeah and you know my time
at s free was was very KPI driven and
hardcore yeah Devonshire was the other
end of the spectrum it was very fluffy
his such I mean really which was which
is great but I realized that I wanted to
make in the middle right so I wanted
kind of a come and it was gonna push me
but give me that growth potential
um because I'd started my own desk and I
was a free 60 new business winner
I knew confidently that I could do that
again at console I just needed the
opportunity to like own something and
and kind of be able to build that so
yeah start on a contract division from
scratch doing a software engineering
from scratch yeah yeah it was it was
amazing opportunity and you know I've
got a lot of fond memories working that
company there that holds really close to
my heart
also mate love that so let's say go into
your own business then so with that in
mind then did you always have like did
how do you always wanted to have your
own business
yeah I guess so yeah really for anyone
that knows me that's listening will
probably tell you that I'm super goals
orientated so okay throughout my career
from probably like you know early
twenties of I've always said like really
aggressive goals and most months in
those years and I'm really hard on
myself if I don't hit those goals so
okay nice those have included like you
know billion X a net buying property
going on holidays just things that you
get to do in recruitment but one of them
was that by the age of 30 I want to own
my own business why is it it's always
funny
it's always fun 26 mate
it's not fair I've got out of the house
of God my business I know it sounds
really stupid right but I feel like I
matured really quickly in many ways and
well I saw on my first property at 20
yeah
was an amazing achievement for sure you
know when a nice holidays got that Rolex
not all the things typically do as a
recruiter but only only my own business
I just felt like I could have done it
before well I wanted to to kind of get
as much experiences as I could and I
felt like at 30 I was probably at the
level and probably the maturity that I
could go and do that and know that I
wasn't going to make mistakes yes or as
many mistakes I mean I guess being more
more sure of yourself as well and who
Ryan Adams is and yeah yeah okay and in
my early in my early years I was very
immature in in in loads of ways and made
a lot of mistakes and I was probably a
dick to a lot of people yeah and at 30 I
feel that I was just in a much better
place right I was married I had kids and
I owned a family home and I just had to
move around experience and I felt that I
would be a better leader to people if
I'm honest and you know owning your own
business isn't always about one in a
lifestyle business or just being a big
biller I've generally wanted to be the
best leader to people so I think when I
look back on my twenties I did make a
lot of mistakes and at 30 I felt like I
was fully ready and I knew who I was I
had your authentic identity and I felt
like I could really inspire and motivate
people and that's absolutely what I've
got them to do awesome mate so cool so
let's just frame up and we'll break down
this whole journey to date mate so start
your own business signify and it's been
going for how long now
so I started the business in July 2016
so this year in July will be four years
old four years cool so it started it on
your own right just just Ryan Adams yeah
yeah started started on my own but I did
start in an office with employees and
that was a pretty brave move you know a
lot of people start really slow and then
once they build momentum they start to
build out a team but I just wanted to go
hard from day one it's it's all or
nothing right I'm gonna make it or I'm
gonna fail so okay so yeah let's break
down this year one them because I think
a lot of people that's that's what
people are most worried about right when
I think about starting a business the
fear of the first year so
so year one then so you said straight
out the bat trout that you hired people
yeah and you know day one started in an
office in London myself two full-time
employees and they won like I mean the
internet wasn't even working
I should have probably just had a couple
of days on my own field the logos on the
wall that the phones are on so yeah yeah
that's open myself and to others sure so
did it did you get investment then or
did you know but an important thing to
tell your listeners is I didn't get
investment but what I've done was I went
through the investment process we have
two really big well-known companies or
people okay that for me was just a
process that I wanted to go through to
ensure that they backed me which they
did okay I've got the option to get the
investment which I declined but it
really helped me just the sense check my
business plan and all of the ideas that
I had were smart and I kind of got that
and that that gave me the confidence
just to get out there fray myself in the
deep end and actually smash it okay mate
cool so um you won and so what just just
to frame out so the end of year one
would what did your business look like
so how many people do you have yeah like
what let's just frame it up and then
we'll break it down
question I'd be honest I can't remember
what I had for dinner last night let
alone I want to say we were like double
figures head come I can't remember
exactly question that's funny
what would what did you do revenue wise
Here I am I think we've done 1.5 million
all right let's find in stock
yeah market may let's [ __ ] break that
down because I like how the [ __ ] is Ryan
done that right so let's let's break
that down so 1.5 million first year and
so and I was a perm recruiter right so
use it so you build a contract so it was
it heavily contracts and that year one
or was it a split or surprisingly so I'm
a contract bill oh yeah I've always been
a contract biller now I value perm but
before yeah you know who means nothing
come on yeah yeah the first year was was
heavily focused on perm okay and I had
to do
Neels for the first time in my life is
that a new business plan it was kind of
more focused on contract we thought that
we'd probably be about 60% contracts of
a 40% perm and first year we were
probably more 70% permanent contracts oh
okay
it was surprising what I realized in the
first year was that it was very
difficult for big brands to trust the
startup to do contract when I was doing
a new market I didn't have any
relationships sure where it's a lot of
people that start their own business go
into doing the same market that they've
always done and even if they're meant to
or not because they're restrictions they
mean we bring client contacts with them
one of the things that I wanted to do
was really respect Malcolm Graham at
console I didn't want to break my
restrictions and also I wanted to build
a business that was slightly different
to theirs and I didn't want to have a
crossover so mmm-hmm I had to I had to
just pick a new market but I'd never
worked before so how do you know I'm a
respect like a so how let's break it
down first six months as you said got in
you had employees didn't have the phones
on but you had the logo on the wall like
what how how did you start acquiring
clients but how do you what do you do so
it was really tough really really tough
at times I'll be honest with you I was
tempted to just think hey you know let
me break my restrictions no one's ever
gonna know but I thought yeah and that
and I wouldn't want someone had to do
that to me so to big it to begin with if
it was all candidate focused like go out
speak to candidates
see be strip lead generate take
mechanics to the market reverse market
be equals yeah just really just build a
footprint like listen to what's happened
in the market and the good news was that
I had like a lot of people that I knew
that I'd ever worked at before that had
gone internal or that I was connected to
unlinked it and my first to quiet wins
the first one was actually sky okay was
awesome so first quite wind sky second
client wind was British gasps yeah see
listen good bronzer which the first
three months were absolutely horrific
so we made the choice myself and the two
guys that started with me let's just
absolute lease one the sky I mean the
ball let's just send them every single
engineer we can find bang
and right and we were getting rejected
offers find new interviews not going our
way
and for the first three months we
actually got no deals no place really no
place Wow
month one was to be expected money to
okay cool this is this is tight guys
mumphrey I'm like wow I've made a
mistake this is how much how much runway
did you give yourself I probably gave
myself about six months of you know not
to like yeah yeah yeah so six months is
like you know if I don't do a deal with
six months that's unheard of for me as a
recruiter ask anyone that's ever worked
me I had done new deals every single
every month about fair yeah you know
start them up from zero by the end of
the month floods fines you know fifteen
you pull it out yeah three months big
fat 0 make zero monk a month for but
just came up buses it's a really and
when I was it still with Squire yeah
will changed the quality of can makes
that we require we actually understood
the market a little bit better really
you know we weren't just like looking at
keywords and see these were actually you
know meeting the candidates getting a
new tech test ahead of you know first
yeah yeah you just up your game you you
just a bit but the thing is that when
when you start recruiting as you know me
it may seem a lot of time ago that
that's that's the hard part the
beginning isn't it like as you build
more confidence and you speaks more
people like [ __ ] quality CV I'm
buzzing to get out like you just get
better at that so in the new market as
thus expected right another another key
point right that was the two guys that
started with me weren't doing supper
engineer in recruitment before before
and they look and they hadn't done my
markets Carla Ivar so rule we all kind
of going into it a little bit
flat-footed but you know what in
hindsight I wouldn't have changed it
because it really made us work hard for
it and then when those deals started
coming in we really had that unity and
we've been through the worst they were
ever going to go through and upon most
three months at beginning the rest of
the time has been absolutely doing there
so how how how did you get through that
that time they make because I think a
lot of people could have packed the bags
in at that stage so I guess especially
when you brought two people along for
the ride right this isn't just you at
home in your bedroom lie
knocking al this is you've got you've
bought in people to come on the ride so
and you're honest I thrive under
pressure like I lit that fire under my
butt I just you know I had I had every
single person I'd ever worked it
probably ruined for me to to fell for
whatever reasons I'd walked away from
from shares in the business that
imminently was about to sell so I had
back there as well and being honest with
you I've done this at the worst time in
the world I yeah you have a challenge on
the way yeah so only time this has come
up
honestly it's mad is it because you like
right if I don't do it now I'm never
gonna do it no I was just a stupid these
aspirations and plans right it was
absolutely ludicrous so yeah but to give
you guys and your listeners a bit of a
timeline so December 2016 I'm getting
married and you know I'm gonna really
good money at console and a secure job
that had been in for nearly seven years
I thought well what the hell I'm gonna
just push the boat out you know I'm
gonna go absolutely wild and whenever my
wife wants the know we're spending crazy
money on a wedding in December 2016 we
just had a little boy so our little boy
was born in September 2015
yeah my wife's on maternity so she's got
no income yeah no sport our family home
which we moved into in December 2015
which was just again so you've got some
sort of indication like for bed detached
house in a pretty hefty area and then
March 2016 I kind of I had that ink that
was going to leave right my weight
imagine that I was gonna just take it
all the way up until December 16 then I
was gonna have my notice and start in
January 2000 and in March I just decided
like look at us enough I'm handing in my
notice I'm walking away and then I
started the business in July 2016 after
being I still had the bad boy wedding to
pay for the big bill is weddings pay for
know that and he wasn't doing any deals
for free moments it was tough and then
to make matters worse console sold their
business in
October of 2016 and I gave my shares
back and got zero from the cell so what
was your got you did no let's just say
enough - is it is it fair to say then
that you had a chip bit chip on your
shoulder then you had to make this work
there was no use no now hold that whole
analogy of you go to an island and you
burn the boats like that there's no
there's no turning back here I had no
way back that was yeah I had no way back
it was I'm either gonna make this work
and we're gonna be successful or I'm
gonna fail and I'm gonna have no money
but no knee I'm gonna have no money but
I would have lost everything that I'd
worked through my twenties yeah I just
wasn't prepared for that there's no way
that that was an option to be honest
with you to answer your question how I
got through that first year was I was
ruthless like I work there's every
single minute and hour that God sent you
know I worked in the evenings at the
weekends I just done everything possible
to pull myself on my business out of
that situation and you know after month
three month four five six as we got to
the end of the year that first six
months we actually done really well and
we made profit in our first year most
not don't do that so we grew our
headcount we grew our customer base and
we made profit so it was okay so so
let's just break down those as you send
an S you spray it down there's nine
months saying cuz in nine months you did
1.5 million in revenue right so
obviously as you said you've got bearer
identifying and understanding what the
hell was a good candidate you're working
with some good brands what war others
some of that what are the other some of
the key things that sort of build up the
momentum and you think we're a key
factor to you and in that year and
profit and haven't done a good first
year so the main thing that every one of
your listeners will probably know about
our business is that we are a niche
expert so yeah on one market together
and that was one of the things that I
took from the investment meetings like
pick a market become famous in it
hunting max and together you all gonna
be able to identify candidates win
customers and you're just basically
going to collaborate you know so if
someone in the rooms got an amazing
candidate but doesn't have a role he
could send that candidate to your
customer say yeah so I mean how did you
identify that niche just
I got a bit lucky is he doing SS but you
know my contact I used to work with him
actually Zack con I'm sure a lot of your
listeners will know him from s free and
he was great great below a great manager
he worked at sky as their head of
recruitment okay and he tried to hit me
up to come working internal yeah and I
just said to him I'm gonna start my own
business and he was like cool I'll give
you your first account by there's some
roles like Nick you guys can help me and
I'll help you so yeah one some of those
first rows word the niche the ended up
focusing on we're Scala and Zack I'll be
honest with you I have no idea what's
good well it's got what is Scala is a
it's it's a back-end functional
programming language very similar to
Java it's a specific language yeah
exactly
okay so how many that use Java I move
into Scala yeah okay so your niche is
that so that when we talk about how
niche to go cuz like from absolute you
interact and and sure speech a little
creamy business owners now like how in
your opinion knowing what you know now
about how important was it for you to
actually really go the whole like mile
deep in her life really parrot of yeah
yeah without I'll go as far as same
about our niche we wouldn't be where we
are today and Aneesh has been everything
for us but also a big thing for us has
been a community focus so we run our own
meetups you know I saw that we've got a
blog section which gets a lot of hits we
have a full-time marketing manager which
i think is really important conferences
okay man you just do a lot around
community and and that that that for us
with our niche has been fundamental yeah
and I so so those nine months really go
into your niche really starting out that
I guess and also part of that then how
how did you find hiring through your own
business because that's always a
challenge I get loads of messages about
it but how how was that first my
monsters working out what the [ __ ] is a
good hire for my business like how did
that really be tough
yeah to be fair what we what we chose to
do and it was again really bold of us
but we didn't want to hire experienced
recruiters yeah when it's a high peak
that come from a sales background or a
customer service background I wanted to
teach them how to do recruitment and
again you know one of the things that I
love is is really being a great leader
and mentoring and training people so
sure I just kind of felt that if I was
gonna go and hire the best recruiters in
the market I probably wouldn't be doing
them the best service so you sure yeah
and the early days we had people from a
number of Quitman background and we
trained them ourselves so today three
and a half years later eighty-five
percent of our business is new to the
recruitment industry
really I mean eighty-five percent yeah
penned by Ryan Adams exactly helped the
world okay cool so going into you two
there mate I'm sure reflects on that
right I had a good first year and what
what was going through your head then
going into year two then because you
quite frankly the clear and ambitious
person but going into year two then what
was it was the growth plan like because
you know some money like was the plan
always to reinvest in the business like
what was that was a growth plan gone
into year two yeah so year one
completely focused on doing UK
recruitment you can really yeah yeah
gear to in the strategy was right there
scout to Europe so we want to attack
Europe and tecna's global so we started
work in the German market the
Netherlands Switzerland Spain Italy and
before we do it we were like truly a
global business really and that happened
in year two and yeah we placed all over
the place relocating candidates which is
really cool like a lot of customers
valued that you could bring candidates
in that don't need a visa from a
different European country and we might
be able to even save ourselves some
money because the salaries were sure why
what and what was the what was the
strategy was it the same strategy to
penetrate those markets like what did
you do anything smart or learn from that
yeah so the biggest thing that got us
into the European markets were
sponsoring conferences in those
countries from of our clients and our
candidates and using social media was a
big part of it so really interest
getting our brand out there blog in
attracting candidates so actually now
that you say it one of our biggest
sorts of methods is our own website so
we get candidate
sign up to our website looking for a job
last year our top performing saw a third
top performing source code was our own
website so really yeah I Brandon really
has paid off us that's mental so and
okay then so in so how much was you
invested in in that in you light and you
won the near to that like did you how
much was you invested in that near to
you to be honest that our website
doesn't cost us loads but we just we've
been really cute and smart with it so we
just blog a lot which means that people
who come into our website to learn and
then by them seeing your brand and
learning when they're then looking for a
job they sure hey these guys are pretty
cool so our website doesn't cost us a
lot but if you look at it doesn't look
like a traditional recruitment website
it's quite a cool sort of like tech did
you all kind of feel to it yeah and
we've got two full-time marketing
managers that helped us to push our
brand yeah our website has been amazing
for us but if we go backwards the main
thing is our brand and our market and
social media presence so they're all
very insolent and they as well okay so
just a quick one than that mate because
like is it fair to say that look at
console how much experience did you have
invested in marketing and doing that and
there'll be a lot of people listening
there it's still zero and they have
their own business right so yeah like no
more you know now like what would be the
advice you give yourself on the sort of
marketing brand piece the beginning oh
they're really being honest with you I
I'm not gonna say I or signify have made
the market this way inclined but if
you're a recruitment company now and
you're not doing this then you're gonna
get left behind by your competition yeah
I think that the world is moving much
more to you know internet-based video
and you know developers and clients want
to want to be able to fill that
personality through for the people
interacting with so it's fundamental you
know we are very quickly we were six
months old and I think I hired a
full-time marketing manager right now
and then we when did you get good did
you get advice to do that lying no it
was just something I just something that
would just really wanted to do I tried
to advise console quite a lot about this
and
whatever reason that's that's how they
chose to run their business but for me I
just thought actually I really want to
be big on social media I want to have a
presence and ya know marketing
literature that we can give to our
candidates and clients that people know
our brand and they and they want to use
us I wanted to be like a recruitment
company of choice rather than you know
as needing to always knock doors I
wanted to Pina coming to us which of
course my everyone wants out right so
okay man click on on that because I
think again people's experience with
that challenges would be because you
said there which is really interesting
you said that the third yeah the third
was at most used source code in
candidates place was your own website so
how how did you like learnings on how
did you go about very quickly tracking
it then and measured because clearly you
were measuring it then because you know
that you spend an X and whoa look
there's a source code here so how how
did you manage that so the first thing
is I would say to everyone make sure you
get your CRM database in order yeah and
your consultants are adding candidates
or clients to your database they should
be using source code so every single
time someone's adding you can see where
they came from
so you can see your yes-man that's just
a really basic thing yes oh really yeah
in terms of our website we have a
back-end so you get to log in and if
you're a admin user which most of my
team are then you can see candidates
that are signing up what they're signing
up for and what they're looking for and
then you then get one of your recruiters
based on the location of that candidate
just to follow up with them briefly
about roles and as I said it's been
amazing last year I think we had a
number of saw my head about looking at
my business plan but it probably is
something like four or five hundred
thousand pounds worth of placements you
made four million now and that that's
that's the part that a lot of people
lack right when because when you would
be speaking to business owners our
recruiters that go yeah but not sure do
you know I mean so that's fair play to
you made to actively from the get-go
really humming at home and measure that
cuz that that's always the trouble with
okay Ron but what's the ROI mate and
you're clearly articulating that and
know that because that give you makes
you more comfortable in investing more
in that right 100% and that's something
that we've really been hot on you know
like every single month I do a business
presentation back to my team on what we
what we achieve last month clients in
London location
source codes challenges successes and
everyone can see it so every single
month we talk about this stuff so we
don't just leave it into the end of the
year always looking at new method always
looking at nice man so everybody really
helps you to mate what did that look
like what did you end revenue-wise what
was that mate the clearest way is that
we've grown by a hundred percent
year-on-year for three years so three
years I think we've done three point
three summer 3.2 3.3 so before we go
into you three or four then like how
like again let's try that dumb eight cuz
again I know you'll clearly someone is
because a lot of people a lot of quite
as a few times like you can only be what
you see right and I think clearly or
someone you wanted to go big from the
very start and we saw numbers you were
saying just off the cuff a lot of people
may have fingers unrealistic and not
achievable right so I'm gonna Schumann
by that point you have quite a few
people in your business but how did you
keep up that momentum um so you said
there that you went straight out of the
UK market startup in and train or
different markets but how did you
continue that momentum and maximize the
people that you go on your business
definitely
so yeah the average dual values in the
European market are big
there's certainly like less competition
so I think that helps as well that was a
big factor yeah that's a big factor but
again I'm just gonna miss out like a
broken record like having a niche market
and becoming experts in it really really
helps me actually a USPS that you can
use the open doors having a team that
are collaborating and hunting in packs
definitely helps social media presence
and you just had an amazing client base
like being honest with you like our
customer base
sometimes I pitch myself and like wow
like we work with some incredible
clients and there's a high volume of
roles so we've been quite delivery
focused we don't often with more
customers because we've got so many we
just need to deliver on those that we
have already hmm that's interesting and
while at that point what was the split
in contracts and Pam did that start even
itself out always it still cost slightly
yeah year two we started to see contract
pay off a little bit because some of the
customers that we've been working with
on the poem basis and delivering on
their then starts to open up their
contractor vacancies to us and
so when you have to provide
documentation to get on to lodge
preferred supply list we then had some
sort history so they can show people
that you know we can run contractors we
do have money in the bank these are
stuff customers that have given us
testimonials and you know there was a
bit more proof in the pudding as such
whereas in the first year it was like
hey please trust me yeah you know don't
want to trust you looks very trustworthy
yeah yeah we had a bit more history yeah
biggest challenge in year to them they
all sounds positive what you say was the
biggest challenge in that year to second
no real basic stuff like time you know
tons precious just trying to be a little
sure you again pulled pillar to post
right exactly that be a leader be a
pillar sort out payroll just just you
pulled in so many different directions
team a car and the thing is like you you
hadn't obviously scaled team stuff that
B hadn't scaled the recruitment business
before so did you seek any help or get
advice that this stays like in year two
or like how yeah how did you know who's
doing the right things so I lent a lot
of my my experience with console which
okay valuable right being a board member
and a shareholder in a business that's
done exactly what I was planning to do
really held I also joined a couple of
different four rooms so the audio C was
great because you're good you're in a
forum of loads of different recruitment
business owners who yeah going through
the same sort of challenges as you and
what was really nice there was just to
compare but to never settle to being
like what everyone else was talking
about I always just looked at everyone I
thought yeah it's great but I want to do
more and be better and grow faster so
where's that come from mate where
where's that meant at like how why
probably just my sports background like
I played really like football since
since you know a young boy and played
for pro clubs and semi-pro clubs and
I've always being a captain or wanted to
be the best that football so I think
just that competitive nature I've just
always wanted to be the best me and if
someone else is doing better than you
actually love it might actually reach
out to that person be like hey man
you're absolutely smashing it you know
what are you doing differently how can I
be more like you and if you do
that with you know hundreds of people
along your career then it's only gonna
enhance what you're doing so I like so
branded myself would like really
successful people whether they're
recruitment or non recruitment and just
thinking that hey I want to be like that
guy
hmm because I think the thing is I'm
sure you've experienced it right like
you have that mentality clear you have
that shoes drive but as you as you're
grown in this business the sort of them
what's the words for you to expect that
everyone else will have that Ryan Adams
fire is is unfair right do you know I
mean it's like how how did you how how
would you call a vein that clear drive
fire look guys look this is what you may
be seen from of people but let our
standards in the bars here how do you
start carving around people I think just
that right it starts with your interview
process and you know if you're if you're
looking to grow business then you want
mediocre then you go and hire mediocre
and then your brand comes mediocre where
else from i want to cherry pick people
that are motivated driven hungry
supermen wishes and they might not be me
but I'm gonna make them the best version
of their self and I do some things that
I don't know if everyone does this in
their business but before someone starts
I get them to write me just a short
document nothing too heavy like you know
how do you like being managed what your
goals inside of work and outside of work
where do you know what can I do to get
the very best out of you and when you
see that you can kind of see what
someone's
aspiring to be like and a lot of things
we do in our environment I think really
helps so we focus on like productivity
nice so I'm not saying that everyone has
to do but if you if you are active so if
you're playing sports or go into the gym
or cycling or running then that will
probably help to clear your mind and
help you to be more productive at work
and have more energy
okay and then we also focus on just
doing like team activities which could
be a 10k or a 5k run or Tough Mudder
just things that are going to get
people's that competitive nature and
team and if someone has goals and you
help them to achieve their goals they're
never going to become more motivated in
the better version of their self so
that's been a key driver for me every
single person in my company never set
goals before they worked here
and now every single person even my back
office staff have dogs that's here I
love seeing people do well mmm that made
that honestly I think that's wicked and
again it sounds quite simple but it came
out quite recently actually and they it
was that it was in a smaller business
but you send that what he does at the
beginning of each year is he gets his
people to write out what they want their
job description to look like and yeah so
I think what what I really like about
that is that you're the people that you
want other people that accountable
accountable responsible for what they
want and sometimes it's got it can't
just be like okay so your targets 200k
okay great but like you'll make you're
making them decide and think about what
they want and understand and it's more
than it's more than as you said it's
quite a lot of things that that can be
right I think that with the goals right
that people find it uncomfortable to
begin with and being honest with you
I've got a very diverse business I think
that's another really key thing so I've
got diverse in terms of like color like
I've got a diverse business in terms
there's different colors different
shapes and sizes but I've also got quite
a lot of women in my company
okay that was something that I sow from
it the very beginning is I wanted to
have like a diverse business I didn't
want to be male dominated but whose
women are greater a lot of things and I
think to have a harmonious environment
you need to have women in their early
often it becomes very difficult to hire
women so I've got some amazing
independent strong women and are coming
that have absolutely smashed it so going
back to the golfing I think that a lot
of these people that worked me right now
never ever like setting goals and never
did and three and a half years later I'm
looking at so many people am i coming
out on properties for the first time or
multiple properties have got this out of
debt and started families who've bought
a nice car gone on holidays got their
driving license it's like just little
things but that's what's important to
them and now that I know what makes
someone take it make it helps me to
motivate them mass that was really my
next point I'm so glad you said that
because that's come up a lot when when
ride Adams Ryan Adams the leader knows
that right so you know what that person
is what I do to really sort of be the
best
employee there can be for you
commercially but you know that they're
motivated to get a house or they're
motivated s this in this you like when
the Hamish it there is light
look Ryan you like do you want that or
not do you wanna yeah I love the way you
said that because yeah then you know
what buttons to push and you know how to
motivate your people everyone's
different right mine pick me and you
although we both have done recruitment
we're not wired the same like we don't
like the shot so I can't motivate you
the same as I would motivate myself and
the same as the next guy so when you
grow your business I think to be a great
leader you really need to understand
that everyone's different everyone
doesn't want to be spoken to the same
way or manage the same way and the
sooner you can identify how people like
to be spoken to and how they like to be
managed and what they're working towards
you can get their very best out of them
so I think that's been a fundamental
thing for me and I I generally feel like
I get on with all of my employees even
people that have left as well and I
really tried to make sure I get the best
out of them and I know that anyone
that's worked for me or has left to go
and work internal or start their own
business or do whatever will take a lot
of the stuff that they've learned from
me and take that into their personal and
work life and and I really try and have
like a positive impact on people as much
that's what can make so you're free then
another hundred percent growth yep so
like what so with that so the when did
to let you moved over to and LA when did
you move over yeah so I moved to LA full
time September of last year which was
our third full year third full year so
in the third year then the growth plan
was did you start thinking about the
u.s. then yeah so we so year one all UK
year to UK in Europe
youngberry UK Europe and us so if we
start to work in the u.s. market full
time from January of last year so 2019
why'd you do that it was just them in my
business plan so again I'm very goals
orientated so I'm really very very very
aggressive business plan which is a free
year plan and the very beginning of
starting signify and each month year I'd
look at that I just think we've just got
to do everything possible to get to
these numbers because that's why I
commit it to myself I'm gonna do yeah
if was gonna work the US market and we
couldn't open an office in LA and that's
so how that whole year you spend
building relationships building business
from the UK but in the u.s. before you
fly over there it was very tough I'm not
gonna lie
myself and two of the guys that now
actually work with me in the LA office
which is yes we sacrificed our personal
life quite a lot so we change our worker
now as we started at lunchtime we stayed
to like nine ten o'clock most nights
really and then the challenge is you
know you get home in the evening after
your train journey and you know 11:00
11:30 at night your clients and hammocks
in the US are still online because
they're eight hours behind you as I need
you know 2 3 in the afternoon nights
where your closing deals and you're up
to 2:00 3:00 in the morning and then in
the morning I want to get up so I can
see my kids so it was it was a really
tough experience I'm not gonna lie I
think we all doubted ourself at points
and we were ready to throw the towel in
because it was it was horrible we've
done it for a lot longer than we
probably needed to but what was it like
trip like what would this sort of
milestones that you plan to get to in
order for you to go right on really
confident now if you go to LA that we're
gonna it's a mental saying there's out
loud right now but I know a lot of
people open an office they move and then
they just get off the ground for me I
wanted us to build a customer base and
do a million pounds worth of revenue
from the UK and we done okay yeah that
was the milestone yeah we've done that
in seven just funded eight cool eight
months
hmm so that that's what you wanted to
get to before you go right okay let's go
to Ellen and we can continue build your
app yeah million it's just the nice
random sure so so obviously personal
challenges for sure
work-life balance young family sure the
missus wasn't too happy that you just
roll in all the time like you know I
mean that my screen challenge so but
what would the other challenges from the
the business like is it as you know as
I'm sure you've seen like there's a lot
of people send the us huge opportunities
bigger fees loads of opportunity but
what what were the challenges that came
up to you get into that million pound
mark yeah so I agree of all of those
points that you just said big
opportunity
bigger door values all of the biggest
tech companies in the world are mainly
based in in America and the Apple Cisco
specifically the challenge is this is a
super competitive market do you mean the
UK market is very competitive but you're
competing against other recruitment
agencies you know you very rarely have a
lot of engineers or software engineers
there that engage direct with companies
about use and recruiters from the
essence of complete different ballgame
so really mainly go direct to the
companies because they've got massive
internal recruiters and start and
agencies out here on that much of a big
thing so when you speak to an engineer
they're like yeah I've got like 20
interviews but they're all direct with
Google Facebook Twitter Netflix Airbnb
and then you're like well hey I'm
working with a couple of really
early-stage startups do you fancy it
yeah it's very difficult in that sense
they don't want to talk to you on the
phone they don't value you as much so
it's overcome that how did you start
kind of tracker severe in you know
perseverance thick into our guns on
we're gonna bring the UK methodologies
that are proven and worked this US
market may be watering down our
aggressiveness and maybe not being as as
its controlling as we would be in the UK
as such and just learn enter balance the
phone with email and with video and just
just trying to relax into the market a
bit and to be honest em we've been super
successful out here so far you know
there's only there's only what four of
us in the LA office at the moment we're
just about to add a fifth head but we're
also open in an office in Austin Texas
in in the next couple of months
how did how how was the coin acquisition
piece how difficult was that yeah I know
so I love BD right so you've got some of
that love speedy loves picking up the
phone yeah but did you did you leverage
the relationships in the UK who had
places in the u.s. yeah a couple but a
lot of it has been new business and I
know we're really well known in our
market if you find a scholar developer
in the world that doesn't know who you
are I would be very very surprised
that's a bold statement but and we are
the world
only Scala specialist agency I know a
lot of companies are trying to do our
market because of our success but we
truly own the space
really ok so let's sort of bring it full
circle then and so I think a big part of
that is which I noticed is obviously the
the sort of the events piece and
sponsoring events and you actually see
did you start a event series of some
sort yeah we did and that that's been
like truly amazing so we started our own
meetup in London which is a monthly
meetup and we use that as a BB tour as
well so we host of customers where we
have a relationship but we also host
with new companies that use Scala and
each month we host at different places
so we've hosted a lot munzo Bank and if
a port our sky just just you know and
just quickly just make it really clear
cuz I've heard this a lot of times now
and nothing would be fair for a lot of
people Ryan to say now events have been
done like loads of people do and blah
blah blah so like how how was it so
firstly BD business development which
typically is difficult for a lot of
people and businesses win a new business
how did it help them with business
development because you go in a
different angle you don't need to talk
about recruitment you know someone like
hey you guys use our technology we're
specialists in this space we host an
event which has around 100 to 150
engineers there attend a each month we
would love to host it in your office to
give you guys the chance to invite a lot
of nobility see what you guys are
working on and you might get the chance
to hire some of these guys direct would
you like to host we've got a slot
available in X months someone would be
crazy the same no to that yeah go see
you can't have been at the beginning
though right hundred 150 software
engineers from the first event it was
snowing I don't even remember this so a
few years back 2017 I figures when we
start snowing band it was Miriam crazy
like London was on lockdown and we're
like oh my god we're gonna have to
cancel this event and we had crazy
amounts of people sign up and we were
like you know what we've committed to if
ordered pizza oven corn in beer and you
just gonna have to go for it and you
know if there's not a great turnout
we'll just blame on the weather
first event there's like 90-something
engineers and we're like oh why do you
think that was why do you think that was
successful straightaway
having really good topics okay having
great speakers and and just just people
wanting to see a start-up do well like
genuinely I think that a lot of the
community that we work to have engineers
really like us because we're super
personal personable sorry and we've met
them at conferences overseas and they
value that we're trying to help their
technology grow and without without our
input in this market I don't know if the
technology would be where it is right
now because you know we've been able to
make here quite public by blogging and
social media and we've hoped to today
we've helped 600 Supper engineers find
jobs in three and a half years nice
means I'm something to be a super proud
girl and that's we're over a hundred and
twenty-five different tech companies in
18 countries globally so you take away
our input the market probably wouldn't
be where it is today so yeah and just
just just going for it right being bold
just what's the worst that's going to
happen if you throw yourself out so but
so fair to say anyone that thinking
about an event or like just again having
another way to build relationships or
whatever that that's generate revenue
for you in your business
Oh 100% because one customers from it
but we've done placements with but we
also meet engineers at these events
people that we're already working with
like oh hey by the way I'm looking for a
job can you guys help of course we know
and I think on the thing the trick here
is and I'm sure you're smart right
you're not that first event it wasn't
sewn so the guys like right how many
business cards gonna go out so now I
want you to enter your pocket yeah do
you know I mean that's not a game right
no you have to be you have to be smart
with this stuff so we don't go there and
like hey we're a recruitment company we
desperately want to get you a job we go
there and we're really relaxed we're
there to help them have a really nice
evening talk to each other and feel like
they're not being sold to and if you do
that with people they'll come to you
when they need you mmm that's a key
thing that is a great question is that
you don't go there like shouting from
the rooftops like hey we're a
recruitment company we really need your
business please work with us you just go
there and you be nice people hmm yeah
okay mate so hit your million pound mark
right and and you move to America in
September 2018 19 yeah I've been here
for six months now six months yeah so
[Laughter]
let's talk a bit about that mate so look
all sounds great and as I'm sure we've
done had it this is a real honest place
right and I think it's fair to say that
if you were to look at the run Adams
profile and signify look clearly there's
been loads of great things right and
[ __ ] now Ryan's doing really well but
like what what's been some of the
biggest challenges for you since going
over to the America there probably we
didn't expect or people probably don't
tell people when trying to take their
business to America or moving their life
there yeah I'll answer that in a couple
of ways so the first thing is leaving my
baby in London right you know I built
the built the business in London I've
got an amazing team and I'll truly miss
them every day and it sounds very random
to say but I don't just see my gonna I
don't just see my staffers like
employees I see them as friends and you
know we've been through a hell of a lot
together
so I've really really missed the guys in
London and you know I talked to them
most days on video and emails the time
different sucks a little bit right it's
like eight hours so when these guys are
finishing work we just start some work
so that's been really really tough and
because we're a junior business made up
of people that don't have recruitment
experience we don't have a massive
leadership team in London so without me
being there that has been a little bit
now how have you have you how have you
have you can have you got things in
place now where light and non negotiable
ways to communicate to the team or have
you got you not I mean how do you
communicate a team yeah definitely so
we've got where we're trying to build a
leadership team so at the moment we're
hiring for seniors principals team
leaders managers directors just to build
out our leadership team and we also now
have a manager of the perm team and a
manager of the contract team and also
we've promoted a couple of people to
that principals and seniors so just
working on building up the structure
we've got a really good back office team
and we've also acquired a full-time
internal recruiter just to help us
yeah amazing Oh we're also using
external training providers that try and
upskill our team and get them thinking
so really investors in the people that
you have in your full yeah yeah and in
house in a challenge and then how just
quickly sorry just so select so I guess
what I'm just trying to ask maybe if
you've learned through doing it and
trying it but like as you said AI was
different there finishing as you're
starting but how have you gone about
communicating like what you need to to
that business like I've you get up every
morning first thing you do email jump on
a video with the guy like how have you
communicate to the guys so I started
like most days and I got up really early
so really I I love starting my day
really early so I get up at 5:30 every
morning I cycle sounds really horrible
right I cycle to work down and hit the
gym and then I start work
I'm physic at my desk I start work at 8
o'clock yeah which is 4 o'clock in the
UK so at least it gives me a check in
with them straightaway yeah ok fair okay
fair enough
so we forms yeah we use Microsoft teams
which has been great for us it's like
everyone has lap top we we use email as
I'm sure everyone does sometimes I like
you know what's that people yeah okay
you know but I definitely I'm definitely
still involved but I trust the team
they've got a great team highly
motivated that have been with me for a
long time but yeah we just need to add
some more experience to help us we have
like structure strategy processes yeah
especially aren't there so ok the next
challenge that makes oh definitely yeah
leaving your baby leaving the people
there that you form great relationships
we've communicating with the guys what
else have been a challenge for you
hiring in LA is tough really I mean
we're right next to Malibu stopping
stopping
agencies probably isn't the most sexy
glamorous thing that like makes the
Hollywood right everyone's in films or
an actress and just finding people that
want to do recruitment is really really
tough so that's been the challenge but
we're trying to do to get that right is
find people again from a number of crew
and background try and train them well
in the u.s. yeah in the US move people
from less desirable locations to LA
because their lifestyle
we're going to be moving a lot of our UK
recruiters to LA as well to help us
build a team and what's the what's the
visa situation that'd be a good fit
what's been your experience of that
because obviously a lot of people have
assumptions on this consumption
assumptions of what that's actually how
is that then yeah the assumptions are
all wrong everyone's like you're never
going to get a visa it's really tough
but again I think if you back yourself
and you put in the right documentation
then you're going to get approval
because we are effectively adding to the
US economy by us working here we're
helping to start tech companies and help
people get jobs and we're also making a
lot of money so it's actually helping
the US economy hit home so what were
some of the things that's really what do
you think that is just because of that
because of the value because there
you've got a real good case of why
they're coming to the country and what
we can add yeah our business case is
strong right we've got loads of US
companies that were working with from
yeah without capital one to I mean we
work with some amazing brand so I think
that helps we're able to make a lot of
value from the UK and everyone that
works in our business is a true
specialist so I think that's what the US
government look look for like can you
find this person in the US and the
answer is no right now because no one
does our market okay I mean for me to
find a scholar specialist recruiter in
the u.s. right now is isn't it
impossible because we're the only guys
doing it yeah fair so what and what is
the actual reality of living there mate
what is the actual la lifestyle that
you've been London for him through what
is it actually like mate I don't want to
rub or anything like that but it's
everything that I could have hoped and
dreamed for like I mean I absolutely
love it just the weather is amazing it's
like it's winter at the moment and it's
like 2021 really it's sunny most days
blue skies is it chilled though is it
the people do people get [ __ ] done over
there it's very relaxed there's not as
much hostile if there is abundant but is
that an advantage for you do you feel
like that gives you guys a bit of a
competitive advantage it's in a bondage
but it could also be a weakness because
if you come here and you allow yourself
to
not work as hard and become relaxed then
you could fall into a trap whereas the
way that our business is stuff is
they're cool like we're gonna take
advantage of the lifestyle but we're
gonna still work like we're in the UK
and that's yeah that's you really yeah
we're in we're in a we work with a first
in and with a last out every single day
mmm and I mean we start work at 8:00 and
we finish at 5:00 so we're not working
crazy out yeah it's amazing like truly
it's beautiful to wake up near the ocean
my kids go to the maintenance school
there there's some celebrities that take
their kids there as well so they're
rubbing shoulders with with some amazing
people meant some friends or from the UK
who are traveling as well so yeah the
guys are settled business is good
I cannot complain it's everything that I
would have hoped from here that's
amazing Matt I think clearly
well-deserved works your absolute socks
off Nate and so with a little hard work
yeah yeah yeah I don't know if you're
ever gonna be someone that's happy when
other night you ever gonna be settled
with whatever I don't know what it is
what you've got on your gold sheet mate
no wife says that all the time she's
like you know when's enough enough and
I'm like never there's no end game
really is there like what they should
there isn't in business like you you can
say you want to get to this point that's
it but it's not like it's for its
infinite right way Zavala I'll be honest
with you my ultimate goal in life is to
be a provider like I love the pressure
and I thrive under pressure so I love
being able to provide for my family and
for my friends I also love being able to
provide for my staff so I know that
sounds great I think we all know about a
situation recently where if a big
recruitment company went into
administration and for me that that
scares me and I take the responsibility
of all of my staff on plus their friends
and family because these guys need to be
paid in as well and yeah after so I
don't know when enough is enough but
we're just gonna keep growing keep
scaling my ultimate goal is to sell my
business or merger their bigger business
in a quicker timeframe than console for
more money that's why
really do they know that I don't really
talk to them but do you wanna do is that
is that because you know what could have
been for you in it you you tapped out
before yeah but being honest with you
the money I missed out on like hey I
earn that now per year anyway it's that
this is what it is right yeah I'm
generally the most happiest that I've
ever been in my life and I think that's
really important to me like I love
getting out of bed every day I don't
love what I do I love the brand that I'm
building I absolutely love every one
that will work with and I wouldn't do
anything different like cut me open I'm
a recruiter at heart and there's some
people that do recruitment to get paid I
do recruitment because I absolutely love
it I genuinely love it I couldn't think
of doing anything different if or when
my business merges or sells or whatever
what will I do
probably still recruitment I can't
imagine doing anything different I would
probably choose being a recruiter I
would being a footballer any day yeah so
look before I show you the last couple
of questions may just soar now I'd love
to just get your opinion on this light
how do you think we can change the
perception of recruitment mate because
clearly you're someone that's passionate
about it absolutely loves you building
the business with everything that you
shared today how do we can change the
perception just keep raising the bar
like yeah every time I do something I'm
like you know someone could copy us and
do something similar but if it's gonna
make the recruitment industry a better
place and make people value us more than
hey so be it you know if every recruiter
moves towards being on social media
great if everything recruitment company
works a niche great because their
clients and talents are gonna get a bit
so it's not raising the standards are
not exactly you know a lot of people
complain about there's so many
recruitment awards for excellence this
is a great thing because it means that
we're all trying to do better join APSCo
and be you know a member of the
professional body talk to other business
owners and aspire to be like them and be
better and just keep doing things in the
right way I would say absolutely you
know we worked really hard but we have a
lot of fun you know we do a lot of
company events we share success we
collaborate we have incentive trips and
lunch clubs and Livia Awards this summer
we we celebrate our birthday every year
I think that's really important as well
so every time we make it to another year
older the whole company gets together we
celebrate what we've achieved we will go
out and
you know just have a great day so yeah
we could make love that so look and I've
got a couple of questions on resilience
and we'll finish this mate so um but
before I ask you those just to sort of
wrap this all up mate
knowing what you know now Ryan Adams and
like what advice you wish you got given
at the beginning of this journey mate I
know you're only four years in but
knowing what you know now hindsight's a
great thing what what would you love
what would be the advice that you give
yourself or advice that you wish you
receive if it's a tough one right
because I'm I thought you're gonna ask
something like that you know that maybe
if you could go back in time what we do
but being honest with you this sounds
like a really kind of I guess like basic
answer but if I could go back in time I
wouldn't do anything differently first I
think that everything happens for a
reason and everything that's happened to
me in my life so far even all the
mistakes I made there's been a lot of
them has made me the person I am today
and shaped me to be the person I am
today so just so you'd say to each the
advice would be keep trust in yourself
trust the process the process yeah you
hear them a lot right and recruitment
trust me who says I'd probably say that
yeah it generally was hard and I
expected it to be then and that's
because I went to knock the lights out
you know if I just started a one-man
band yeah that's what that's what you
want isn't that like that so that's why
so that it's nice not for everyone that
that for me I love being around people I
couldn't think of anything worse than
sitting at home I'm at ya know where I
just couldn't think of anything worse I
love talking to people other people I
could talk to a brick wall right so yeah
it was harder than I expected
talk to people that's that's probably a
big one right there's a lot of stuff in
that in the world right now seek advice
help get help yeah mental health
well-being and I'll probably just say
talk to people I've got an amazing
support mechanism around me like I can
talk to my wife about anything my best
friend
Daniel Lawson and works for me in my
London office
he's my manager I talked to him about
everything we've been through the worst
times and a life together but also the
best times in a life together and we
built this company together jack who
works in London office he'd be Murray
from day one as well a share month if
I'm going for a bad time
work personal life I just tell them how
it is right there my friends they don't
judge me I didn't judge them so I
probably just say yeah like talk to
people you're not on your own however
bad it may be like know that someone's
there they've got your back yeah love
that man so three questions on
resilience and then actually the last
question mate I've got an event coming
up in a couple of weeks which is why
I've been asking a lot of people on
resilience because the theme is
cultivating resilience and going a
distance in recruitment so this is the
first question mate what does resilience
in recruitment mean to you it's a tough
question because this is the the reason
why a lot of people don't last right
resilience the me ins everybody think
man you've got to be fixed skinned in
this game and if you're going to do it
long term you need to be able to handle
the pressure and the stress and the bad
times and I know your podcast is called
the recruitment rollercoaster but it
generally is this an 8 year are the best
hires they're like they're the ultimate
feeling that you get yeah
the lows are the worst lows yeah and you
don't really get you don't really get me
in between you get like the mad highs
and then at all-time lows yeah it's
either resilience is just about getting
through the tough times and knowing that
if you get your head down work hard
you're gonna get through anything and
paint it's temporary you know doesn't
last forever mmm nice it's Indians is
everything I would like to say that I'm
a very resilient character right and
that day when console sold I'm not gonna
lie I left the office and I was broken
like in fact I'll be I'll be mad and say
like it brought a tear to my eye was
knocked off because I worked there for
nearly 7 years and I knew that might
impact help their business get there and
I didn't even get like I didn't even get
a pound or a door a thank-you card so
that really really upset me and I was
gonna leave the office and go home and
just be you know angry and gonna have a
beer and I just well actually know what
and the globe Atkins waffles I'm gonna
tell everyone what just happened
and I'm gonna tell them that has really
hurt me and I'm down about it but I'm
gonna get through this I'm gonna get on
the phone I'm gonna make some [ __ ] up
and write my lover love that man
resilience is everything if you don't
have resilience you're not going to be a
good recruiter
yeah so um how has the importance or
need for resilience
as the industry's evolved I think the
industry is evolving a lot and you know
there's a lot of easy things that you
can do in recruitment now from being a
recruitment coordinator - maybe not
needing to put yourself under stress and
you like BD & 316 group so I think it is
changing it's a moving environment but
I'd say depending on what companies you
work for you can vote someone have an
easy life but your might may be not
gonna earn the best money if those goals
so I think in all in all honesty like
the best recruiters that I know work in
environments where they expect big
things of you and they're gonna put you
under a little bit of pressure so you
can get more out of it mmm though it's a
tough one this is a really tough one
okay that's cool last one what can
people do themselves to instill
resilience in their team's lead from the
front and show people what good looks
like that's one thing that I would like
to always say that you know if I tell
someone to do something isn't only
because I would do it myself
yeah I don't know how to I'll show them
I'll train support help them this
probably isn't answer you're looking for
but I think that resilience probably
comes from loads of different things
it's like how you were how you probably
were brought up some of the stuff you do
in your personal life and then kind of
character you are right so I look for
people that are winners and that are
doing a lot in that person's life or its
self-development goals orientated eating
well taking care of their personal life
you know if you're going out every night
of the week and getting smashed then I
don't know if that's going to help you
to be productive and show better
resilience at soft times they're just
people that are just like serious
characters that really want to be
someone and so I think as a leader you
need to show people what good looks like
if someone isn't being led by someone
that shows great resilience how can you
expect them to yeah nice man
so that before Ashley the last question
what's Ryan Adams excited about me what
are you excited about what you a shout
about just just the general growth that
we're going through and like I said half
of me is super excited about it but then
the other half of me being a bit of a
cynical persons like you know this this
could end at any time you know yeah
granted especially with the news of
other stuff that's happened the market
recently so I'm not sure if we if we
said this but like last year in our
third full year we got to about six
point I think end up in six point six
million turnover the egg and we grew by
100 percent year on year we finally
broken thirty head cam which i think is
a really big achievement for us to
offices soon to be free this year the
plan is to grow by a hundred percent
again so we need to get it cuz it's a
big round number night then gonna be
five hundred percent name we've done it
for three years why can't we do it for
four and we want to grow our headcount
by a hundred percent as well so we're
trying to get to 60 heads by the end of
this year so look what's your space will
work in progress we're doing loads of
things right there's some things that
we've probably done wrong along the way
we've had some churn recently where
we've got a really high bar and if
people not up to our standards then we
start to part company with them and
that's okay but the team that we've got
in place are super motivated billing
some great numbers are top billing last
year first of all year working for my
company billed just under six hundred K
Cheers yeah we're doing we're doing
amazing mate honestly Congrats mate were
chaps socks off and it's a last question
and if Ryan Adams could communicate to
every single recruit out there they take
on your advice and implement it what
would you say these people may it be
phrased sentence work what you want to
say to the people mate it's a tough one
I could go on for days right but I'd
probably say that just love recruitment
for what it is you know like generally
it's a great industry and a great career
I've met some amazing people from work
in this industry and I wouldn't be the
person I am today and I wouldn't have
done half of the things that I've been
able to do in my personal life about
being in recruitment so just yeah be
proud yeah be proud to be I generally am
proud to be a recruiter but one hand you
know before when someone asked me in a
bar like what are you doing my recruiter
traffic warden yeah
[Laughter]
actually like the lowest of lower times
but now I generally chest pumped out I
love doing what I do I'm proud of what
we're doing with doing things
differently so generally like enjoy
being a recruiter if you don't love it
you could probably still do it right but
I feel like you need to love what you do
to be passionate hmm I hope you
understand where I'm coming from
yeah yeah totally yeah if you're not
passionate about what you what you do
and you don't love it you have limited
success so you're gonna have limited
success you're not gonna enjoy getting
out of the bed in the morning that's
probably gonna show in the way you
interact to people internally and
externally on social media on your call
ill show up and all areas in your life
on that for sure life life is short and
I genuinely mean this and we all go
through
crazy stressful times real fighting
battles that no one knows about but if
you if you use recruitment in the right
way it can it can really help you to be
an amazing person you if you work in the
right business you're gonna have a team
of people around you like supporting you
and helping you through and if you ever
need something whether it's money or
someone to talk to that person will be
there for you and I know that my company
so just enjoy a recruitment for there is
nothing keep raising the standards keep
doing great things
let's just keep growing our industry
like there's more recruitment companies
starting than ever and it's a super
competitive market but we don't need to
we don't need to fight against each
other we can all be friends
yeah there's enough money and
opportunity in this in this industry for
us all to do well and I generally mean
that in my only is I used to hate
recruiters yeah any anyone was recruit
on that I hate you
yeah I hate your suit I hate your shoes
yeah right now I love recruiters I see a
recruiter I'm like man I'm proud that
you do yeah I think that's what's chair
and that's what's exciting to see